you've played every fallout like so many
times right now that finding water chips
gex and Liam Neeson's is just a breeze
for you it's time to get back in the
saddle for another post-apocalyptic
role-playing game right not so fast
things are different this time around
veterans pay attention Paul out pours
new systems will [ __ ] you right off that
saddle and newcomers listen up to this
video has got some serious help for you
know sure it's fun to figure out things
for yourself I agree but I've seen too
many of my companions wandering the
wasteland with such fucked-up character
builds I wouldn't hesitate to put a 10
millimeter shell in their cranium for
their own good so what do all the
character stats do how does leveling up
work is the third-person view still some
janky ass [ __ ] now keep watching to find
out
first thing the special system this is
the first and only thing you dump points
into when initially starting your
character skill points are gone tagged
skills are gone no traits and perks are
completely different forget it all
forget everything you know about
previous Fallout games now each special
category does affect your character on
its own strength determines inventory
carry weight and melee damage perception
increases accuracy and vats endurance
determines how many hit points you have
and how long you can sprint charisma
opens up dialogue options and grants
better pricing when bartering
intelligence affects how many experience
points you earn luck determines how fast
your critical meter fills and the
chances of finding better gear got all
that okay so don't worry too much about
that you won't be locked out of using
big weapons or power armor if your
strength is too low your vats accuracy
will still be ok if your perception
sucks and besides when you level up you
can put points into any special category
at any time okay now here's the second
part to this whole special thing to pay
attention every point you put into a
special category will unlock another
perk and there are 10 perks per category
per letter right so you could put 10
points into charisma from the beginning
and unlock all the charisma perks but
but you don't actually have any of the
perks until you spend another point to
activate them and you can't do that
until you earn points in game from
levelling up so while you don't actually
get the perks in your initial special
allocation you get access to them you
unlock them and then you can easily
activate them once you've leveled up and
get a point
then each perk has an additional rank
that can be leveled up by spending
another point on it and those are gated
by your character's level ok that was
the most important part rewatch that if
it was confusing so because of this
setup perks play the main role in your
character's progression do you want more
damage resistance that's a perk you want
more damage with rifles or pistols
that's a perk do you want access to
better gun mods that's a perk and so on
and so on some perks are just simple
boosts your abilities like your melee
damage your hit
points or action points your carry
weight but some give you completely new
abilities now lock-picking and hacking
are also dependent on perks now and you
will want to activate these and level
them up early as to not be frustrated by
the large amount of locked off areas
that are accessible only by either
lock-picking or hacking so deciding
which perks you want and how early you
want them that will help you decide how
to allocate your special coins at the
beginning as I said you can still put
the points you get from levelling up
into your special attributes you'll gain
the benefit of that attribute naturally
and unlock more perks that you can then
activate the next time you level up just
be aware of putting all your points into
the base special categories early on
because you'll be passing up the
benefits of activated perks like for
example nerd rage this is the level 10
intelligent perk and I had it activated
with my very first level up and it's
great now here's another thing in
fallout 4 that changes the way you think
about your character build crits are
completely different now every hit in
vats fills a bit of a crit meter now
when you fill the meter you then
manually execute a critical hit it does
more damage gone are the dice rolls and
the modifiers that determine critical
chance so I like using a modded 10
millimeter pistol that I looted off a
mobster early on because I can fire it
so many times in bats each hit filling
the critical meter and then I hit the X
button on the x box to execute a
critical and you guessed it there are
perks that play into this so perks that
boost your crit damage give you a chance
to instantly gain a crit with every hit
in vats and even one that allows you to
bank them for later use everything is
dependent on this perk chart know it
love it figure it out you never get
stuck going down any path with a fallout
4 levelling system and as long as you
keep leveling up you can allocate points
to anything theoretically maxing out
everything it's a whole new waistline
out there in the Commonwealth but now go
forth with this knowledge and carve out
a worthy life in post-apocalyptic New
England
you